hello everyone and welcome back to the
thing today I'll be taking you through
the adventure of not only our favorite
Disney Princesses but the New Adventures
of their families that came right after
happily ever after this generation of
princes and princesses have a lot to
learn from their parents as adventures
from magical powers and learning how to
control them to following your dreams no
matter what comes in your way and so
much more be sure to keep on watching
till the end because I know you will
definitely be able to relate to these
Disney kids and how they work their way
right out of trouble let's start off
with the life of one of Disney's
first-ever princesses Snow White
this dizzy princess definitely does not
need an introduction she followed her
desk me to become the fairest of them
all meeting Seven Dwarves in the forest
getting poisoned by an apple but
ultimately being saved by the one and
only Prince Charming according to
Mattel's ever after I franchise Snow
White eventually went on to have her own
daughter her name is Apple right buckle
is just as beautiful as her mother with
skin white as snow lips red as a rose
and long blonde beautiful look Apple is
super excited to take after her mother
and rule over her kingdom except we all
know that being a princess is never
really that easy just like her mother
Apple needs to follow her own journey to
learn lessons of friendship kindness and
bravery along the way
there is no better place to learn these
things I've ever after high school where
Apple gets to hang out with all their
fairy tales character friends getting to
know each other and hanging out check
out these photos of Apple and their
friends and be sure to check out Netflix
as ever after high for more on the Royal
and rebels adventures if you've seen our
video on 10 Disney Princesses rematch
with his parents you know that Jasmine
makes for an amazing and beautiful
mother if you haven't be sure to click
on this link to take you there now check
out this fan art of Princess Jasmine by
deviant art user dark matter Nova we see
jasmine looking amazing with her
adorable son in her arms according to
the Disney descendants her son's name is
Aziz now I don't doubt that the young
prince will have many adventures of his
own but not before enjoying an amazing
and magical childhood Princess Di's gets
to enjoy growing up with some amazing
pets like Abu and even Iago this young
prince will never be late to school with
his magic carpet taking him soaring
tumbling and freewheeling through the
magical skies of Agrippa ask for genie
and all the wishes he could grant Aziz
it seems as though aladdin and Jasmine
are going to have a lot of magical
mischief to worry about this Disney
princess taught us that the only way to
get what we want in life is through hard
work she even brought us one of Disney's
catchiest tunes
almost there that's right guys this
Disney Princess is none other than Tiana
Tiana is personally one of my favorite
princesses of all time and for so many
reasons
for starters Tiana never once stops
being the brave and sweet dreamer that
she is unlike so many other princesses
and even her best friend Charlotte
Tiana's dreams never once included a
prince she instead wanted to own her own
restaurant and become a chef
which is definitely a cool thing to want
if this princess became a mother we know
that her kids would be just as gorgeous
as she is and just as hard-working Walt
saving up for her very own restaurant
Tiana worked at two restaurants at the
same time telling me that she is not
going to let her children enjoy too much
laying around there is just no stopping
this independent princess making me hope
that Prince Naveen is ready for his next
adventure as a father
check out this hilarious photo by artist
Isiah Steven but not to worry mama
probably be there to babysit the new
kids whenever they need it in 1997
Disney first brought us the movie that
introduced us to all the gods of Olympus
and even the cutest demigod and human
couple Megan Hercules pinkies and Meg's
love story is one for the ages with
Hercules even deciding to stay on earth
with Meg instead of going back to
Olympus to be a god life without Meg
even an immortal life would be what most
people don't know is that this couple
was set to be in the Hercules - movie
that never ended up being produced what
we do know about the movie is that it
was set to include Herc and Meg's new
adventure in Athens with their demigod
baby girl heavy thanks to another
deviantART user Sparrow's Caribbean we
don't need to think too hard about what
you might have looked like this artist
imagines her beautifully as a perfect
mix of Hercules and Maggie's good look
while we still have to wait on Disney
for a look into what meg and her
daughter's relationship looks like we
can tell that their life was nothing but
magical Meg is undeniably one of
Disney's boldest and baddest Disney
characters of all time it took a lot for
Hercules to win her over and she did not
play any sort of typical damsel in
distress I'm a damsel I'm in distress I
can handle this have a nice day we sure
hope that have they learned a thing or
two from her awesome mother who won
Hercules is too busy saving the world
from Titans and mech kind of just needs
a me day Abby still has both her God and
mortal grandparents to keep her busy now
this mother is last but definitely not
least on our list now I know what you
guys are thinking else's love interest
isn't yet to be determined by the Disney
creators but that does not stop us from
imagining exactly what her life would be
like we just couldn't help but look into
what this Snow Queen would be like with
some magical children of her own I like
the open gates we are never closing them
again check out this photo of Alison
with her adorable baby boy by artist
Isaiah Stephen he has some white silver
hair just like his mother with some
clear icy powers of his own it would
definitely be cool to imagine Elsa son
as Jack Frost himself - Elsa's capsule
would be anything but ordinary with some
friends like Olaf to keep them company
and even some visits from her sister
Anna
these guys have arendelle looking like a
winter wonderland in no time
Elsa has probably learned to control her
powers by now and so will be a perfect
role model for his son just think of all
the fun you'll be having with all his
new snow friends and if honest kids are
anything like she was they'll be really
good at sneaking in there for some
winter fun too
and that is all I've got for you today
guys be sure to let me know in the
comments section below who you think
would make the coolest Disney mother
thank you for watching guys and I'll
catch you next time